a long time ago the flat kingdom was  threatened by the third dimension but  just when all hope was lost  a wise sorcerer appeared and created six  magical jewels keeping this emotions  stable and restoring peace until one day  the masked thief pets kidnapped the  princess also taking one of the jewels  with him that caused the sweetie chaos  to come back  cooking the kingdom in serious danger  again when everything seemed to be lost  these were new that there was only one  being able to save the brain meat that a  brave little - a hero  his shape at will transforming into a  circle a triangle or a square he can  overcome all kinds of obstacles and  geometric bones  now is your time to learn and master  news  fights giant asses to recover the jewels  and save the flat Kingdom